[Música]
las cripto monedas han seguido cayendo
esta semana como el bitcoin el desplome
está afectando a inversionistas de todo
el mundo incluido el gobierno del
salvador el país centroamericano ha
invertido millones de dólares en el
bitcoin y lo convirtió en moneda de
curso legal hace ya nueve meses
alentando a las personas a usarlo para
las transacciones del día a día daniela
blandón por supuesto en este espacio
conmigo para hablar de lo que estábamos
diciendo de esta fuerte caída del
bitcoin o danny cierra o lee como lo
decíamos tiene mucho que ver con el
mercado porque esto es un cripto activo
son inversiones de riesgo entonces ahora
como las tasas de interés están altas
pues la gente dice vamos a sacar esa
platica que te lo hago en estas
inversiones tan riesgosas si nos metemos
en algo más seguro más seguro vamos a
hablar si es seguro la inseguridad del
bitcoin y cómo está digamos en líneas
generales estar cripto moneda y también
por supuesto enfocado en el salvador
vamos a hablarlo con la noguera media es
abogada especialista en el blog y cripto
activos sido de legal rock players
gracias ana por estar nuevamente con
nosotros en este espacio de france 24
llamado directo américa hablemos primero
de la situación actual del bitcoin qué
tan riesgoso es en este momento esta
cripto moneda
hola chicos buenos días cuando siempre
es un gusto estar acá con ustedes
conversando sobre sobre escritos yo creo
que voy a replantear tu pregunta va a
ser un poco atrevida porque no es
solamente lo que está pasando con
bitcoin es lo que está pasando con la
industria financiera a nivel global
debemos entender que hay distintos
factores exógenos
que no tienen que ver solamente con
bitcoin sino con la economía mundial y
que están afectadas tanto en los
mercados financieros tradicionales vemos
por ejemplo como eeuu acaba de aumentar
las tasas de interés que era un tema que
ya se estaba previendo desde hace meses
que iba a impactar a la economía vemos
lo que pasó con china a nivel de
pandemia vemos lo que está pasando con
la guerra entre rusia y ucrania el corte
de las cadenas de suministros vemos lo
que está pasando a nivel de crudo y
gasolina en eeuu y obviamente todos
estos factores hacen que no solamente
bitcoin sino que el mercado financiero
internacional se vea afectado yo te digo
aquí tener planteó la pregunta porque
fíjense que incluso las grandes
tecnológicas como facebook como amazon
como tesla han visto una merma en el
precio de sus acciones por lo que esta
crisis financiera o este crack del
mercado este play market no solamente en
vigo sino también
las otras industrias ahora bien tal como
lo decía dani en el prólogo que además
fue muy acertado claramente los
inversionistas intentan deshacerse de
los activos financieros que son más
riesgosos que son más volátiles como
bitcoin y tratan de poner su dinero en
inversiones un poco más seguras hace un
poco más de dos meses leíamos que a
pesar de la inflación y a pesar de la
volatilidad por ejemplo el sector
inmobiliario en españa y va a crecer un
400% pero lo cierto es que ni siquiera
el centro inmobiliario se encuentra
exento de lo que estamos viendo a nivel
global claramente lo que está pasando a
nivel de volatilidad con bitcoin es una
clara consecuencia del mercado es una
clara consecuencia de que los grandes
inversores institucionales están sacando
sus fondos de bitcoin y del ha escrito
monedas y los estén colocando en lugares
más seguros además es importante
recordar que cuando obviamente hay más
oferta que demanda un activo
evidentemente el precio va a caer así
que te diría que lo que está pasando con
big time depende de muchos factores y
depende primordialmente el sistema
financiero tradicional porque la
industria es cripto no está desconectada
ni de la bolsa de valores ni de lo que
pasa con los bancos ni de lo que pasa
con él y eso es importante resaltarlo
como explicarles entonces a los críticos
que han dicho que el salvador al haber
puesto el bitcoin como moneda de curso
legal se está arriesgando demasiado está
arriesgando su economía inclusive el
fondo monetario internacional también lo
dice que les podemos explicar a ellos
yo creo que hablar del celador es hablar
siempre de una apuesta bastante
ejecutiva de ukelele que bueno más allá
de sus prácticas que para algunos han
sido populistas y han sido anti
democráticas el salvador ha intentado
des intermediar esa histórica figura o
dependencia del fondo monetario
internacional del banco internacional de
pagos y de otros organismos que para
nadie es un secreto se han encargado
históricamente de controlar lo que pasa
en las economías internas así que
viéndolos ese punto de vista creo que es
una apuesta bastante lógica de un que le
ahora bien destinar fondos públicos para
invertir en bitcoin claramente puede ser
una apuesta en esposa que creo que el
gobierno de bucle no lo ha hecho a corto
plazo sino pensando en un mediano en
largo plazo vemos por ejemplo como hace
un par de días el ministro de finanzas
del salvador había dicho que la caída
del precio del beat coin solamente
representa un 0 40 por ciento del
patrimonio de esa nación lo cual yo creo
que es bastante interesante porque hay
ese comentario que le respondió bueno
entonces nos estás diciendo que debemos
comprar más bitcoin así que pareciera
que la apuesta de duke le sigue en
marcha y obviamente es una apuesta
bastante arriesgada pero contra lo que
muchas personas creen que el salvador
está perdiendo dinero debemos recordar
que el salvador hasta el momento por lo
menos no ha hecho un discurso al público
de que haya vendido sus bitcoins así que
en teoría el salvador sigue teniendo los
mismos 2300 bitcoin que posee en su
balance habrá que ver cómo se comporta
el precio y a corto o mediano plazo pero
lo cierto es que la apuesta a google es
no solamente deportiva es arriesgada
pero yo creo está enfocada en el mediano
plazo y hasta el momento no pudiéramos
hablar de pérdidas como está claro hasta
el momento entonces anna esto sería una
inversión que está ahí dormida pero
cuando ya el gobierno en salvador
pudiera arriesgarse digamos ya ya poner
a valer ese dinero por así decirlo
yo creo que tal como te lo decía creo
que el gobierno de el salvador el
gobierno en equipo que le está esperando
claramente que el vic o el aumento de
precio de hecho veíamos hace meses como
en una de esas grandes subidas porque es
importante recalcar que aunque le ha
estado comprando en forma escalonada es
decir que le no comprar 60 mil lo que él
ha venido comprar todo cada vez que el
precio de vitico encaje yo creo que es
una apuesta bastante interesante de
hecho ellos tomaron parte de esas
ganancias para construir creo que un
hospital para mascotas y un par de obras
de infraestructura pública que han
podido sacar de esas ganancias que les
ha producido el comprar mil en forma
escalonada yo creo que es una apuesta
repito a mediano plazo y aunque
claramente compromete las finanzas
públicas y aunque claramente ha tenido
oposición dentro de esa nación pareciera
que a mediano y largo plazo pudiera
tener éxito recordemos que el salvador
es un país que ha dependido
históricamente el turismo y que por
primera vez abre su economía a
inversionistas a extranjeros para que
vayan a con arco ping en ese país y yo
creo que es una apuesta válida
anna el bitcoin parece pues que llegó
para quedarse como todas las criptas
monedas pero también vemos que han
pasado cosas qué pasó con luna que ya no
sé explicar a usted bien qué fue lo que
pasó y con otras empresas y los riesgos
a que es esta inversión
cómo hacer para tranquilizar también a
las personas que están intranquilas por
eso qué sucede con la script o monedas
tan riesgosas que son y no reguladas
ok la primera vez que hablé con él les
decía y esto es algo que muchos bitcoin
erse a muchos inscriptos lovers aunque
yo lo soy no les gusta que digamos
supermercado esto es un mercado todavía
bastante nuevo bastante volátil bastante
desorganizado tal como lo decía dani
hace un momento es un mercado que carece
de regulación a nivel global siguen hay
países que se han esforzado por avanzar
en la regulación no es la norma es la
excepción y eso hace que el mercado sea
susceptible a distintos impulsos desde
un tweet day lomos hasta lo que anuncia
china variando la minería hasta lo que
haga vaivén o lo que haga cualquier
gobierno que puede representar algún
impacto negativo en el precio de vito en
específicamente en lo que está pasando
ahora mismo con el mercado cripto me
hablabas de luna a mí me da un poco de
pena hablar de luna de tierra y de vives
y por qué es el ejemplo perfecto de que
cuando hay proyectos
centralizados pueden pasar esta clase de
cosas básicamente lo que pasó con luna
es que bueno su fundador en este punto
pudiéramos decir que es un estafador do
kwan básicamente lo que hizo fue
manipular el proyecto sacar dinero
comprometer el dinero en protocolos
donde le prometí a la gente un
rendimiento del 20 por ciento de
rendimiento que además era irreal y que
en algún punto iba a ser que este
proyecto no pudiese cumplir con ese
rendimiento y eso ocasionó que millones
de personas perdieran dinero e inclusive
hay reportes de personas que se han
suicidado como calmar a las personas en
este punto señores es importante que
entiendan lo siguiente invertir en
cripto es invertir como el indicativo
que tiene riesgos siempre decimos lo
mismo que son un poco clichés primero
con research es decir investiga el
proyecto en el que estás invirtiendo
segundo no pongas dinero en estas
inversiones que no estás dispuesto a
perder y lo más importante nuevamente
por favor educarse investiga porque
repito y es por ahí desde todavía es
inmadura es verde y carente de
regulaciones